this really has not been able to find
that three-point stroke on the season as
davis will
[Applause]
lay it up and in for the possible
three-point play exactly what happened
but davis too big too powerful you see
the push into the body of davis but he
is a load
giddy
wisely passes away from deandre jordan
basically that is a tough shot and much
like he did in the first half even with
anthony davis in the vicinity with the
step back three
gladly take a trip to the free-throw
line my goodness
wow that's on anthony davis who's got
really quick at the basket
and davis goes right over the top using
his length again just takes it away from
baseley and it leads to a cutting base
more to deandre jordan for the slam the
thunder had the lakers attention here
not yet three minutes into the third as
westbrook hard drive puts his head down
fakes it in counter to the foul
and he even got part of the ball but
westbrook stayed with it yeah well he's
coming in so fast the lakers trying to
get out and run westbrook sprinting full
steam ahead try to slow down the
basketball doors going to knock it away
there's the lakers turnover and he will
elevate for the slam
but it's not how you start is how you
finish you got a lot of basketball left
in this game but you sure do like plays
like this for fix the big group has a
sweet stroke she's like a guard can you
shoot me from 18 feet out
sga double team quickly realizes get rid
of it giddy
[Applause]
sometimes you got to play this game off
the streets
and that's just a street move
an eight-point game rondo ready to check
back in they're getting tended to
momentarily sj season crease goes to the
rim scoops it up off the backboard
a lakers rebound but you got to love the
fact that the thunder just continued to
make plays like this la just didn't have
anything going offensively
with the thunder
slowly inching back that's going to miss
oh the sga
steps back even a little surprise from
him
a bucket could potentially go into the
fourth quarter with a lead sga defended
closely by westbrook
tough step back gets up the shot
[Applause]
the third quarter
sga show on full display from 26 down up
by two
[Music]
this is a tough finish too because avery
bradley is a terrific defender takes the
hit
with a lot of vigor
as giddy trying to get it down fenders
finds himself open as
dwight howard was completely out of
position a little back to the basket
action here on reeves
he's the arty with four threes
thunder trying to go inside outside
tough fadeaway and what a shot by roby
banking it in
mello this is mellow hello but it's just
besides here
second free throw no good now for the
rebound davis muscles his way up
basically
access denied
top of it
how about this here
just a big time block
by baze and a tooth and claw your way
back in this ball game
lakers are sending the double team at
shea wanna get the ball out of his hands
and that moves north open with a lane to
soar up for the slam
and westbrook floats the pass out to
monk
under a minute to go
monk trying to drive and lays it up and
in over the outstretched arm of favors
and it's a one point okc lead
fears right now it's giddy giddy around
the corner back to favors inside
the beautiful dump and finish and it's a
three-point okc lead well the lakers
wanted the ball out of sga's hands and
that's what the thunder did they took
advantage of it and put faith in the
rookie with yet another assist michael
he's got 10 on the night and this one
was big oh this is a big time and this
has to be a baseball pass because
clearly time is not on their side and
that's the ball game right there
and it'll be daisy
capping it off
with the slam after the turnover
by los angeles